fifty-eight goddamn seconds of goddamn
logos followed by nearly two minutes of
black screen opening credits look I am
never gonna hate a film directed by a
guy named ball okay also cleverly
disguised narration reading God oh look
out looks like we have a Captain America
in our midst
violinist stand up come forward wow this
is a crazy number of violinists to still
be alive amongst the tiny back of the
Train population sit down
Wow reversal in less than two minutes
out of the first incident what's the
lesson for the viewer here that both
these assholes are stubborn
unpredictable dicks or that everyone has
a rebellion breaking point okay so
they're looking for the protein block
that has the secret message in it but
how do they know which one has it how
was it marked and isn't it lucky this
kid didn't bite into it and swallow the
capsule before they got here also how
many kids have swallowed the secret
message before they got here
Octavia Spencer shows up in your lack
she's slumming but then later after you
realized the movie is awesome you're
like oh she was reversed slumming and
I'm a dick entire movie will gloss over
how this train is able to operate with
frozen track conditions discount still
alive John holy SH I don't understand
why Tonya didn't simply tell her kid to
crawl back to the sleeping quarters way
before this there are no guards behind
all these parents so a kid could easily
crawl his way back without being seen
guy who played a hero literally frozen
in ice for several years and a different
hero whose powers were based on fire the
opposite of ice and who appeared in
films titled The Iceman playing a cool
and Winter Soldier will now grimace
while watching snow and ice torture and
I'm positive this means something I just
don't know what but I'm sending that
they give her seven minutes for a speech
to tell them they already know which is
a long damn time but apparently in the
length of the speech is directly
proportional to the amount of time it
takes to freeze this dude's arm off I
belong on the head you belong on the
foot yes so it sees I defy you to prove
to me that Tilda Swinton isn't going for
a Michael Caine impression here I simply
refuse to believe otherwise by my count
you have nearly 5 more minutes but I can
see how you think you spoke longer than
that I mean I was wondering when you'd
shut up you don't know what Maisie said
she said put down that useless gun yeah
why did she say that anyway kind of
amazing such an important aspect of your
illusion of control is given away with
such a careless slip of the tongue the
used Apothic bullets
forty years ago in the last revolt how
come you guys didn't figure this out
long before this four years is a super
long time where you've studied these
people picked up on careless things they
say and so on to only now figure out
they ran out of bullets come on
this is like a boss with an easily
exploitable weak point every time he's
at the apex of his swing you launch into
his ass but these guys are gonna pretend
like this is something difficult to get
through for a suspense sake open it
necessary orders ma'am are you listening
convenient Babel Fish technology just
happens to be on the train in the
prisoner section a minute ago Mason
scolded her interpreters because she
didn't have time for them to translate
her speech but they have these
convenient things for the prison section
she's an addict too whoa dude hold off
on the labels you need us help so the
protein blocks are made of icky bugs but
I'd like to think Curtis is getting sick
from all the CG on water supply section
yes few cars up if we take it we have
the upper hand we don't even have to go
to the front these asshats were planning
a revolt any day now and they have no
idea where they should go they just
learned about the water car and its
location the stood sending notes is a
fair for not mentioning that earlier and
yes I know who's sending the notes but
these guys should at this point be
questioning the note writers
authenticity since he just wham heed
them with super important information at
the last minute how old you 17 back away
slowly dude earth what was he like well
see it was warm and green and how the
have you been on this train for 17 years
and not once overheard someone talk
about what earth was like are you
clairvoyant well you always seem to know
us behind the gates casual clairvoyance
how in the name of reason do these
soldiers justify wearing hoods that
cover up their eyes do they know how to
use the Force see how callously we kill
this innocent fish do you don't think we
will do the same to you or wait are they
just coating their axes pre battling
some catfish blood because if so the
beverage will ever get started
axe wielding dudes versus people who
don't have weapons I guess Curtis has
crew or winning this but I have no clue
how I'm gonna guess by the sheer luck of
film editing and extreme close-ups
they'll come out of this alive how are
any of these people good at hand-to-hand
combat after 17 years on a train new
years on this train is so important
these evil soldier dudes all still do
the big unison countdown even during an
all-out brawl it's at this point I once
again have to ask the strains been
running the same tracks from the same
bridges for 18 years in frigid
temperatures and
just wondering how the maintenance of
said tracks and bridges holds up that
long in those conditions
apparently forever which means second
laws of thermodynamics here's yet
another reason why this train could not
stay in motion for eighteen years in a
row also this almost has to be something
that happens more often than it does yet
it rears its ugly head during the fight
scene because honestly that fight scene
was getting pretty tiresome anyway also
literal visual roll credits this train
goes far off the tracks and somehow does
not derail why are there not killing
people the United Nations isn't going to
impose sanctions if you commit war
crimes in the situation carve these
motherfuckers up there's the tunnel
right after kitane they're great yeah
maybe you should have attacked all these
fools while mason was talking huh movie
turns into a night vision castle
wolfenstein of some sort this asshole
here chops his own dude this is why you
don't fight in pitch darkness
somehow this supremely lopsided fight
will still end up with enough troops on
both sides for the battle to continue
somehow these assholes when we think of
this half way through the darkness fight
we're sending fire up to a darkness
fight let's send a kid and let's take a
long time making a big ceremony out of
the whole thing like it's the Olympics
or something my question is what is
everybody doing they're all just
standing there not killing those filthy
talese this whole shot doesn't make
sense also suddenly everyone has fire we
saw one torch a second ago
oh no not Bucky Amina edgert also Edgar
dies fulfilling the current Chris Evans
best friend needs to get killed riding
on a training requirement in his
contract also there should be massive
amounts of dead bodies on the floor but
I think there's like ten principal
character who dies gets his eyes closed
by someone cliche it was right about
here that I realized there was no way
this character wasn't going to be played
by Ed Harris I didn't even know he was
in the movie but The Truman Show guided
the wig Wilfred knows you well mr.
Curtis Everett this should be a huge red
flag for Curtis man yet it is not you
know tell that to Jim Abbott dickhead
jeez how many takes to this require to
get right is this entire train car
devoted to peach oranges and is that
Bilbo if you only have sushi twice a
year how does this guy keep his skills
sharp is he making sushi the other 10
months but not letting anyone eat it
because it's practice sushi or is he
such a master he can literally go six
months between platings and still
execute a perfect ten sushi plate you
eat this I carried it this whole way
through many battles and yet it's still
completely intact this kid saw the other
two kids get taken through this car
which probably means these kids are in
this car at all hours of the day because
if I recall
Andrews punishment for trying to hide
his kid took place at night so the real
nightmare is these kids are in school 24
hours a day and on holidays since it's
New Year's Day at all that's literally
all they say about how the train can
stay running all this time and it's not
even an explanation mr. Wilford knew
something they did not and what was that
old word people were frigging moron the
other nightmare of this classroom is
that they are taught this Wilford stuff
24 hours a day which is proved by the
fact that every one of these kids knows
all this stuff by heart and were once
again shown a video about it I think I'd
rather stay in the tail section I also
wonder is this the only classroom
conquer kids of all ages on this train
or did they control the births to only
happen once every 13 years or so so they
can keep on classroom
engine stops we even the song doesn't
have any damn answers also what the am i
watching 15 years ago in the third year
of the Train seven passengers tried to
stop wilford's miracle train Jesus each
new car they walk into just happens to
be chugging past some important landmark
in this trains history this thing goes
around the world and passes by many
nondescript areas but on the day of the
revolt it's a veritable history lesson
I guess shooting these guys chains off
is really that easy yeah I guess this is
sad but for an audience member this
feels like sweet relief this poor
bastard was already mostly dead and I'm
not talking about the Princess Bride
where you hope he could hang on the man
had an umbrella for an arm first act of
this leader in supposed hero's regime
murdered it out of someone I feel like
this training should be running into a
lot more snowdrifts than it is the
director said let's have an entire state
room car devoted to a creepy dude
peeling an apple it'll make the front of
the train citizens look even more like
assholes Oh Dennis office I bet his ass
is busiest considering he's the only
Dennison this train also have a doctor a
shrink an optometrist a urologist
so the schoolchildren marched through
all these can train cars on their way to
school every day
also I actually kind of feel bad for
these entitled people on the train
because everywhere they decide to be
they have to walk through miles of train
to get there unless they have some sort
of Transportation on the side of the
Train like an uber or something so this
is a cool movie and we enjoyed the doubt
of it but especially this part here
which is as clever as anything you'll
see in an action movie so we will remove
five sins for this awesome
good to see the train has pools for its
elite members but these are some really
awkward and truly fools week the kids
also walk through this yellow Darth
Vader room on their way to school
do we even ever get to see the apartment
cars where the fucking families live we
don't
outstanding guy trying to stab another
guy but they have an arm wrestling match
before the stab happens cliche if man
could somehow hide in here then
certainly yo know could have hidden
better than she did but I'm trying to
figure out where the hell dam came from
in this super small compartment fine I
promise
uncapable promise the movie will make
capable way to long death scene is way
too long they killed that old guy from
that one movie then they killed the
black lady from the help now he's
finally pissed enough to fight back I'm
still keeping track of all the train
cars the school kids have to pass
through on their way to the school car
which is now like nine cars back and
this is the weirdest car yet and I can
only imagine the kids
walking through these tattooed unisex
hookah orgies asking each other hey who
was the 11th President of the United
States Tom I think it's obvious at this
point that whoever wrote the part of the
script that contained the schoolroom
walked off the project and a new writer
was brought in and was told nothing
about the schoolroom sequence okay so
how many residential cars did they skip
over to get to this point I mean there's
a whole society living on this train but
no one apparently has a home to get back
to the students stay in school all the
time the Reavers rave and so on it makes
me wonder if the teacher got impregnated
while in class just the husband people
in an iron box how did you not all die
within weeks after a month we ate the
week the following scene is a harrowing
tale of cannibalism and the tale of how
Gilliam took off his arm so that a young
Kurtis wouldn't eat a baby Edgar that's
all fine and good but what I'm wondering
is why did Wilford even bother picking
up these people if he never intended to
feed them if he truly needed Talese to
produce child labor to keep the engine
running wouldn't you want them to
survive you know I hate myself I know
what people taste like chicken I know
that babies taste best veal that baby
was Edgar Billy Elliot he died like a
bitch you should have eaten him back
when he was delicious it was the man
with the knife he told this story and a
third person to make this reveal more
revealing this guy has been wasting the
last cigarette on earth and then one by
one other people in the tail section
started cutting off arms and legs and
offering them what the fuck really
what did you do with all the blood and
how can that many people seriously get
through the cutting off of their own
limb without anesthetic or other drugs
this is a book beer also in an alternate
universe these limbs were all supplied
by the Star Wars prequels and no one had
a self dismembered do you think my
station is without its own drawbacks
it's noisy and it's lonely but did you
eat baby that wasn't what Gilliam and I
had in our plan what no don't tell me
you didn't know yeah it was so freakin
obvious the way Gilliam kept helping and
planning stuff out for the rebels he was
clearly working with Wilford
Oh miss Gilliam almost a late night
phone check he could go on for hours
Oh only one arm what does the number of
arms someone has have anything to do
with their ability to talk for a long
time this guy has a knife stuck in his
belly he's been bleeding out unless you
tell me he's a cyborg he should pretty
well be dead well good thing Yona woke
them up before this guy came in for the
attack by the way where was her clear
voice during the scene
okay I'm gonna star me here but this is
a classic bottleneck Annie
these two people should be able to
handle this army one at a time Julian
well understood we need to maintain a
proper balance of anxiety and fear this
whole scene here at the end is so
reminiscent of the architect neo seen
from the Matrix Reloaded that I wonder
if they took the script and simply
changed character names and swamp matrix
for train I want you to take my station
well just as vague as ever why did you
write this stupid note anyway because
you wanted to keep tradition alive you
know that the guy you need to
communicate with is right here right and
you may as well have written vague
message on this and it would have been
the same damn thing you must tend the
engine keep her humming but I know
nothing about engines and you've taught
me nothing look at them that's how
people are the crazy guy justifies his
actions because humans are awful cliche
that piece of equipment went extinct
recently we needed a replacement thank
goodness the tail section manufactures a
steady supply of kids so now the truth
comes out about why they needed the
people in the tail section it had
nothing to do with balancing a closed
ecosystem they needed kids to run the
engine problem is Wilfred says the
engine problem only happened recently
it's recently 18 years ago because how
did you know you needed a small child to
keep this running way back then
matchbook climactically only has one
match left by the way when did all these
angry red people suddenly decide to stop
trying to get across the bridge to kill
nan they were pretty pointless
thankfully this climax happened in the
Himalayas for optimal survival chances
Yona entities survived this so there's
hope for Humanity after all um but is
you only gonna have to have sex with
Timmy when he's old enough to do so or
is there pope that there are survivors
around the polar bear might be a clue
that humans might have survived too but
let's say they are the last two people
on earth we have that whole Noah's Ark
argument again and I'd rather not think
about that
you
fate depends
moments such as these are matters of
faith to fail is to invite doubt into
everything we believe everything that we
have fought for
he'll never bothered me anyway there it
is it's huge
that's incredible do I look like
I know what people taste like I have
been watching you your whole life
I was watching when you were born
watching when you took your first step